the U.S and China are fighting a war
it's not a war that you can really see
and it's not a traditional Battlefield
war with soldiers at least not yet this
is a war that's being fought in
government offices and Company
boardrooms it's a war that's being
fought with rules and regulations and
it's meant to stop Rivals from getting
their hands on the most important
technology in the world
microchips you might hear them called
semiconductors microchips or integrated
circuits these are all the same thing
we're going to call them chips
microchips tiny pieces of metal that are
magic and that run our world
this is a big thing that's happening in
geopolitics right now and I want to help
you understand the stakes of this new
conflict between the US and China it's
going to be the center of global
attention for years to come what we're
seeing right now is how boring trade
regulations and business rules can
escalate to something that can impact
your everyday life because your life
depends on chips whether you know it or
not in fact
let me show you everything has silicon
in it anything that has any
technological smartness to it is a
product of silicon
that's our tone
[Music]
oh and it's not just like The Usual
Suspects techy things yep microchip
my refrigerator silicon my microwave
silicon
no I'm just playing with you this
doesn't have silicon in it
[Music]
this is just a few little things I found
around the office but like Silicon is in
your refrigerator your microwave like it
is in your digital clock it is what
makes our world go round I mean we are
speaking through silicon right now like
you are watching this on the internet
that is made possible because of silicon
on a screen that is being fired by a
silicon chip like everything is silicon
in our world besides like the forest or
something or like you know
analog cameras so microchips make our
economy possible but it's not just Tech
it's not just a consumer Tech it's also
military the military needs microchips
the microchips for weapon systems
getting microchips for intelligence they
need microchips for AI they need
microchips to stay ahead of their rifles
microchips represent geopolitical power
because they represent military power
that's something to just keep in mind as
we go through the story House of
Representative Nancy Pelosi is in Taiwan
tonight China is already responding lead
the world in future Industries protect
our national security we're in the
middle of one of the most fundamental
changes in the character of war in the
history of mankind
tape pause I feel really strongly that
the internet is a place where you can
learn to level up your professional
skills I learned all my skills on the
internet that is how I know how to
animate and edit and film and do all of
these things the sponsor of today's
video also believes this thank you
scaler for sponsoring today's video
scalar is a place where you can go and
level up your skills as a programmer or
engineer scalar is a short-term
accelerator program it's like 8 to 11
months and it's meant to enhance the
coding skills of software professionals
basically make you way better at your
job and then to help you get a better
job a big part of the scalar program is
to hack the job recruitment process to
make you better interviews to get you in
the right doors so that you can get
better skills and then a better job in
this industry in addition to their
curated computer science course they
offer one-on-one mentorships with like
software professionals who are like on
the front lines of this industry that
give you referrals it really is just
like a One-Stop shop if you want to
level up as a software professional if
you like me have a career in a very
quickly changing Tech technology-based
field you know that things are always
leveling up and the best way to stay on
the front lines is a program like scalar
that will accelerate you that will help
you get in the right doors and that will
give you the skills that you need to
stay on The Cutting Edge of all this
stuff I am a giant proponent like
philosophically of the idea that you can
bypass big institutions where education
is usually done and learn to level up
your skills on the internet like giant
fan it's like a principle for me and
that's what scalar is doing here they're
giving you access to level up your
skills to become a better equipped
software professional and then to go get
the job that you want in this industry
so if you are a software professional
who's ready to grow their skills scalar
is the place for you there's a link in
my description clicking that link gets
you in on a free live webinar where you
can go get a flavor for this trust me
your career will thank you thank you
scalar for sponsoring today's video
Let's dive back into microchips
[Music]
in 1959 the U.S was about to get very
lucky computers at the time were
becoming a thing but they kind of looked
like this tons of wires connecting
everything all of them sending little
precise electronic signals to each other
to solve tedious complex math problems
it was clunky it was inefficient it
wasn't very special yet but then two
American Engineers that were working
separately at two totally different
companies had a very similar idea the
idea was to get rid of this all these
wires there was this new technology that
had cropped up called a transistor it
was like a really precise reliable on
and off switch allows you to control
pulses of electricity super precisely
but at first transistors looked like
this they were big and clunky lots of
parts so the idea was what if we start
carving these little on and off switches
onto a material called silicon it's like
a super abundant metal like material
inside of Earth's crust but it's
actually a horrible conductor of
electricity if you mix silicon with
other elements it conducts electricity
really well it is a semiconductor of
electricity exactly what they needed to
precisely control the flow of
electricity very accurately no more
clunky long wires let's just carve our
little transistor switches onto the
Silicon chip a single circuit that way
we can fit a lot more into one place all
close together so that's what they did
and then the world changed forever with
the transistor man has gone far toward
matching some of the capacity of the
human brain okay real quick aside here
we're gonna get to the geopolitics and
stuff but I was so curious about one
thing why does being able to precisely
control the on and off switch or like
the flow of electricity do anything to
change the world well it turns out this
is where my mind bends a little bit just
stick with me here so transistors can
turn on and off and they send a signal
that results in one of two things a one
or a zero when it gets to the other side
super boring and useless if you just
have one little transistor sending a one
or a zero but if you have a thousand of
these switches all sending little
signals in the right order suddenly you
have something that kind of resembles a
little brain firing signals in a
coordinated system that can actually
solve logical mathematical problems and
literally remember things this is kind
of how our brain works it's pulses lots
of pulses and now we're talking about
Computing this is how computers work
[Music]
the first light the more pulses of
electricity you can control the more you
can do with technology and suddenly
there's a new gold rush in the United
States but the gold is now silicon and
the rush is to put as many of these
little switches onto that silicon chip
as possible so that we can make our
technology do more and more
sophisticated stuff and now people have
smarter clocks and TVs and radios and
video games and calculators things that
you can hold in your hand and press a
bunch of buttons and suddenly the
Silicon chip is solving math problems
for you instantaneously what is
happening this is Magic oh and it's not
just Tech Bros in the 60s who are loving
this the US Military and NASA are first
in line to get their hands on these new
Chips they dream of using them for more
sophisticated weapons or going to the
Moon chips were becoming a currency for
National Power
we've got to protect him thinks the USA
luckily the USA didn't really have to do
much to protect him at first they were
killing it they were the global leaders
of this chip making stuff every year U.S
companies crammed more and more
transistors onto this little piece of
silicon more calculations per second
more and more companies are now cropping
up to make dreams come true with their
new magical microchips lots of this
action was happening right here in
central California in a valley that
would soon take on the name of the
material that enabled all this magic to
happen by the mid-1980s they were
carving nearly 300 000 little on and off
switches onto a piece of silicon oh and
look it's Steve Jobs and Bill Gates
yeah they're using these more
sophisticated silicon chips to change
the course of history home Computing
color televisions more advanced
satellites and smaller and smaller
electronic devices of all kinds there's
a revolution happening and over the next
30 Years the number of transistors that
they can fit onto a piece of silicon
starts to become ridiculous and it's
like the 90s and these things are
getting faster and smaller and now
humans have computers in their homes
that are more advanced than the ones
that were used to land on the Moon Not
only do they play the typical computer
games that all the kids enjoy but their
curiosity for learning has skyrocketed
and look it's even smaller now it fits
in your pocket and we are calling it
iPhone
thank you
none of this is possible without these
little magical brains made of silicon
okay but then a problem arises and it
has to do with these these look like
just factories where they make
microchips right no these are not just
factories we have a special name for
these they're called Fabs and they are a
central part of this story because
listen cramming tens of millions of
transistors onto a piece of metal-like
substance from the earth is hard to
begin with but as the number of
transistors continues to double and
double and double making them becomes
incredibly complicated I mean look at
these operations this is inside of a Fab
and the reason why it looks like they're
doing open heart surgery here is because
even a single Speck of dust that gets
into this Fab and onto one of these
chips can totally ruin it so yeah it was
American companies who are designing and
making chips but every year they have to
spend more and more on these tedious
Fabs these factories on steroids they're
getting really spendy like billions of
dollars spending meanwhile an ocean away
you've got a couple of economic Miracles
happening in all of these countries in
East Asia that are rapidly developing
and they want in on this microchip Gold
Rush
foreign
countries is Japan where a bunch of new
tech companies were getting really good
at making chips and they could make them
and sell them for way cheaper than the
US oh and by the way this was with the
help of the Japanese government who's
like subsidizing this governments love
microchips that's going to be a theme in
this video
the US is hating this they're kind of
freaking out that Japan is getting in on
all the chip gold rush they got to do
something about it so it's 1987 and the
US government basically says no more
Japanese chips they put a 100 tax on
Japanese chips coming into the U.S which
not surprisingly just crushes Japan's
chip industry too bad so sad Japan said
the president at the time who was wait
what the hell Ronald Reagan the profit
of free markets and free trade what's
going on here our aim is to increase our
national wealth so all will have more
Well turns out that chips are really
important so important in fact that Mr
free market economics abandoned his
principles to protect American ships
this is a theme we're going to see a lot
more of it okay so let's move on
meanwhile another Asian economic Miracle
country is growing super fast and wants
to get in on this but they also were
looking over Japan and they're like we
don't want the US to squash us for
trying to compete with them so if we
can't beat them let's join them
[Music]
oh and this is a really important
foreshadow here Taiwan is looking over
here at their neighbor China who's also
getting really rich and more serious
about making good on their lifelong
promise to eventually invade Taiwan and
quote reunite it with China kind of
scary so in the back of taiwan's mind
they're also kind of looking for a way
to get the West to protect them so they
made a bet a freaking brilliant bet that
solved all their problems at once at the
time a bunch of engineers in Taiwan were
actually leaving Taiwan to go to the U.S
to go to university there and then to
actually work for U.S companies in The
Cutting Edge microchip economy Texas
Instruments Intel so the first thing the
Taiwanese government does is lure them
back they guarantee them jobs they pay
for their travel costs to give them tax
breaks to create companies their goal is
to create a Silicon Valley in Taiwan and
it totally works it's like a reverse
brain drain thousands of Engineers
returned to Taiwan to start companies
and to help build the microchip industry
in Taiwan and one of those Engineers is
the one who actually changed the game
it's this guy named Morris Chang he had
the best idea of all of them he had seen
that American chipmunkers were hating
how much money they had to invest in
these Fabs these really complicated
factories to make microchips his idea
was instead of trying to compete with
the United States in the chip industry
and get crushed like Japan did let's
become their friend let's solve their
problem we won't design chips we won't
make devices we won't make the software
here we will just make the chips
themselves we will become the masters of
Fabs the tedious expensive job of
getting more and more transistors onto a
piece of silicon so he starts a company
called Taiwan semiconductor
Manufacturing Company tsmc super
promising and creative name Morris and
the government of Taiwan is super into
it because now they can get in on the
chip Gold Rush and instead of pissing
off the United States they actually will
solve the US's problem and crucially
make the US reliant on them so now they
have protection a silicon shield to
protect them from their big aggressive
neighbor the government gave nearly half
of the startup costs to Morris Chang to
start this new Venture they connected
them to venture capital and according to
Chang himself the prime minister of
Taiwan even called a super rich
Taiwanese investor to force him to
invest in tsmc
whoa okay uh yeah wow like you can see
just how vital chips are a little piece
of silicon with a bunch of on and off
switches tsmc was basically a
state-owned company from the beginning
so yeah taiwan's now in the game and
semiconductors are now becoming a
geopolitical bargaining ship ship a
geopolitical bargaining chip
I kind of regret it
[Music]
go in here and I'm tired I believe I'm
going to be the nominee so it's like the
early 2000s and semiconductors are now
squarely a part of geopolitics but
meanwhile in business World in Silicon
Valley they are loving this Taiwan
situation because now instead of having
to do all of this expensive tedious Fab
stuff they can just do the design and
the software and the business side of it
and they can just ship it off to tsmc
and they do the rest taking on the
expensive tedious work of maintaining
their Fabs and keeping them up to The
Cutting Edge which requires billions of
dollars every year like to keep some
perspective look at this graph this is
the number of transistors on a piece of
silicon by 2010 they're now getting a
billion transistors onto a piece of
silicon the size of your fingernail and
the only way to do that is to make each
one of these insanely small so let's
just take a moment to blow our own minds
here each transistor is becoming smaller
than a width of a human hair wait no
sorry that's actually way too big of a
scale a human hair is like 90 000
nanometers thick we need to go smaller
like a red blood cell Wait no that's
still too big seven thousand nanometers
okay a virus something that's not even
totally alive it's so small wait that's
14 nanometers still too big I mean we
are getting into insane scales here IBM
recently revealed the chip with
transistors that are two nanometers
thick making them literally smaller than
a strand of DNA so in these Fabs the
reason it looks like this is because
they have to figure out how to do this
and to keep doing it and keep making it
smaller and smaller providing the world
with the most advanced chips and this is
why we have have nice things your entire
world revolves around what is happening
on these little strips of silicon
[Music]
for more and more U.S chip companies
don't actually have Fabs they design
them they do all the software and the
machinery and the selling and the
business but the actual making of the
chip happened in Taiwan but as 92
percent of all advanced chips are now
made in Taiwan what this means is that
the US is completely reliant on tsmc
basically and finally we're getting to
the conflict this is where China becomes
really important because China the most
populous country is suddenly very rich
and they want new tech too so they
become actually a giant customer of all
these chips buying 40 of all the chips
in the world meaning that they are now
reliant on the US who is reliant on
Taiwan to design and make their chips so
let's look at the Modern chip industry
as it all comes together which is going
to set the stage for how this conflict
is playing out today here's a very
simplified version of the supply chain
again very simplified it's just insane
I'm not going to go into the full thing
the US is the one that manufactures the
machines the software and the designs
Japan makes metals and chemicals for
chips the Netherlands makes this crazy
UV laser machine that you use to carve
the chips and Taiwan crucially does the
expensive tedious job of actually making
the chip almost all of the most advanced
ships in the world are made in Taiwan
and then you have China who is the giant
customer in all of this they're the ones
who are buying more and more chips to
grow their economy I mean look at this
beautiful supply chain you've got a
bunch of countries that are involved now
everyone has a part to play and everyone
depends on each other for chips
globalization is great economic
interdependence is a recipe for peace
and mutual prosperity
right I mean it used to be
but there's something else happening
with the supply chain that might be hard
to see in this diagram which is that the
US is still the Kingpin of this system
they're the most important player they
have the most important ingredients the
best designs the best software and the
most machines to make chips Taiwan their
bestie has the second most important
ingredients in all of this the Fabs that
actually make the chips China on the
other hand is in a position of weakness
their role is basically the big hungry
chip consumer totally reliant on their
Frenemy the United States and their
annoying neighbor Taiwan who they want
to invade but now they're reliant on for
Cutting Edge chips and what's at stake
here for China well it's not just their
economy they don't want chips just so
they can have a bunch of cool Tech they
want it because more and more they need
Advanced chips for their military
[Music]
it's like the 2010s China's military is
getting kind of scary but it's not that
scary since the us we're not that
worried we'll always be ahead of China
when it comes to controlling the supply
chain and our military gets first dibs
on all the best chips China has no
chance of catching up ever and this is
true China was truly behind they did not
have the tech and the designs and the
companies and the ability to make
advanced chips they were reliant on the
United States if China pissed off the US
they could just take away their chips
and now we have a rising conflict on our
hands
China this big superpower is not going
to let this happen they realize that
they have to do two things number one
they have to start making their own
chips they want to break free and stop
relying on the US for anything make
their own chips so that the US doesn't
have leverage over them and number two
and deeply related is they want to
continue to build up their military to
modernize it to build more warships and
satellites in high-tech missiles and
drones and eventually AI all of this
needs Advanced chips which they don't
have so they're like we are going to
make them on their own and the US is
like good luck China you're so far
behind good luck trying to figure out
how to do this thing that we've spent
the past 60 years figuring out how to do
make really expensive chips experts in
software and machinery and Fabs like you
have no chance so how is China going to
catch up lucky for them in China there's
a blurry line between businesses and the
military it's all kind of overseen by
the state and also lucky for them there
are loads of U.S tech companies that are
addicted to making money by selling
microchip technology to China so instead
of invented themselves they see an
opportunity here need software and
equipment for your new chip industry get
it from the US need fancy chip designs
and software U.S companies have you
covered need those high-tech chips
produced for your military projects
American companies will sell them to you
and yes tsmc in Taiwan will make them
for you wait China is using U.S
technology to get ahead of U.S
technology what in 2021 The Washington
Post reported that China was building
super Advanced Laboratories to test
scary new weapons including nukes and
guess what they were using American
Semiconductor Tech to do this it started
to become clear that American companies
were selling Tech and chips and software
to Chinese tech companies that were
actually just a front for the military
wow
yikes the U.S chip industry is now
allowing China to get ahead this was
starting to happen but I think what
really woke up the U.S is when this
happened a huge step forward in China's
military China conducted two tests of a
Hypersonic missile system technology
that would allow it to fire a nuclear
warhead faster than anyone else the U.S
does not currently have the ability to
even track this weapon much less to feed
it
U.S military generals wake up one
morning to discover that China has just
tested a new weapon a missile that flew
around the entire world going five times
the speed of sound a mile a second oh
and it's really hard to see because it
flies below radar range it's super
Nimble maneuverable and has the ability
to carry nukes the U.S had been working
on something similar but China beat them
to it by years and it was American
microchip technology that helped them
build it oh
[ __ ] yikes
I've totally caught them off guard says
that U.S intelligence Services had no
idea that China was so far ahead it
turns out that while the US government
thought that they were running faster
and that they were fine they were
actually fueling the rise of their
biggest rival by giving them the
technology that they need to get ahead
so the U.S decides that they've got to
do something China is ahead on these
missiles and they might get ahead on
things like Ai and they're doing it with
our Tech no more free trade no more free
markets the government is jumping back
into the chip game to sort this out
fundamental change is taking place today
politically economically and
technologically all right Joe Biden's
like rolling up his sleeves he's like
what do we do here step one cut them off
no more chips for China the Biden
Administration published a large set of
export controls on Friday in order to
slow beijing's technological and
Military advances and restrictions will
limit Chinese companies access to
Advanced computer chip
dude
and here we are back in the fun
bureaucratic paperwork Department of
Commerce Bureau of industry and security
docket number
220930-0204
certain Advanced Computing and
semiconductor manufacturing items
supercomputers and semiconductor and use
entity list modification
this is just a bunch of rules that says
no more chips to China all those Cutting
Edge chips that China was buying from
U.S companies blocked restrictions will
limit Chinese companies access to
Advanced computer chips manufacturing
equipment they need to make their own
chips block all that us-made vital
software that Chinese companies need to
design their own chips block block block
we will bring these jobs back to our
Shores and end our dependence on far and
chip in fact the bite Administration
went super far to say that any company
globally that uses U.S tech to produce
chips is now blocked from doing business
business with Chinese firms to cut China
off from certain semiconductor chips
made anywhere in the world with U.S
equipment why stop there Americans are
now forbidden from working for Chinese
chip companies this is huge news like
this is huge news this is happening this
is like we're in the middle of this
right now but let's go back to that
visual of the whole supply chain if you
cut off this then yeah you hurt China
but you also hurt the other side of this
line U.S chip makers like one example
this U.S chipmaker Nvidia they went from
selling tons of chips to China to
suddenly being banned from doing so this
has led to a 400 million dollar loss in
Revenue in just one quarter poof up in
smoke one of the biggest chip makers now
totally cut off from their big Customer
because Joe Biden is afraid of the
Chinese military and for good reason
which leads to step two of this policy
the bind Administration wasn't going to
leave these tech companies out dry so
they gave billions of dollars to
American chip makers to say hey yes
sorry we cut you off from your main
custom summer because we're kind of
getting scared of their military but we
have to protect our chips here's a bunch
of money Congress passed the chips act
which gives billions of dollars to these
companies to create Fabs back in the
United States this time it wasn't Russia
but China another rival power would get
way ahead of us if we didn't pull out
all the stops and this legislation is
the first large step in pulling out all
of those stops government wants the Fabs
to come home to ensure that this most
valuable technology isn't solely reliant
on outside countries and we're talking
giant payouts 50 billion taxpayer
dollars go to companies like Intel which
is now opening a new Fab in Ohio we are
going to build the most advanced stuff
in the world right here in Ohio or even
tsmc themselves which is based in Taiwan
but is now opening a new Fab in Arizona
keep it in the family okay so this is
economic War and the Biden
Administration just did a huge move
reminder that the reason why this is
important is because it's not just about
like business or even missiles this is
about chips chips are not just chips
chips are the future chips are power yes
chips mean economic growth and new cool
technology but chips also mean new
weapons chips are the currency of
geopolitical power kind of like what oil
used to be but now it's freaking silicon
with a bunch of on and off switches on
it the US is taking control of its
valuable resource and cutting China off
so the US makes this big move Cuts China
off and that you know this is
geopolitical conflict they just made the
move the ball's in China's court now how
will they respond and this is where
Taiwan comes back into the picture
[Music]
Taiwan this small country that finds
itself in the crossfires of this
conflict 92 of all advanced chips are
made here mostly by tsmc the US is
totally reliant on them a few months
before the Biden Administration was
doing all of this making it illegal to
sell chips to China Congresswoman Nancy
Pelosi visited Taiwan not just to like
shake hands with political leaders no
she was there to visit tsmc the chip fab
what Pelosi was really doing here was
signaling to Taiwan that they are vital
to American Security U.S relies on this
and will protect it came to Taiwan to
make unequivocally clear we will not
abandon our commitment to Taiwan and we
were proud of our enduring friendship
and in doing so she shows us what
China's counter move might be in all of
this it might be Taiwan are you willing
to get involved militarily to defend
Taiwan if it comes to that yes a
commitment we made okay but wait what
this doesn't mean is like China is going
to invade Taiwan and like take all the
chips or like take over the Fab or
something that scenario doesn't make any
sense if China invaded Taiwan all they
would find is a bunch of empty Fabs if
they weren't bombed already they
wouldn't know how to operate them they
wouldn't have all of the engineers in
the software and the all of the supply
chain stuff that they would need to
actually make chips they would likely be
fighting a war and the US would probably
get involved I made a whole video about
it you can go check it out anyway the
effective counter move here for China
would be to operate right on the edge of
active warfare to strike back at the U.S
without provoking a military response
this is how big nuclear powers do it
they don't actually Clash they want to
just sort of poke at each other one
scenario would be China sending a bunch
of its Navy ships to set up in the ocean
right around here creating a kind of
partial blockade that could stop cargo
ships that are coming to and from the
island kind of just slowing everything
down but really holding the Silicon
hostage making it hard for the supply
chain to actually work I mean just
remember like the covid-19 chip shortage
or like supply chain shortage or even
like the Suez Canal blockage from a
couple years ago imagine those supply
chain issues but like on steroids
totally debilitating and being used for
a hostile purpose to strike back at the
U.S like Biden forbidding American
companies to sell chips to China the
blockade would be a way to strike at
your nuclear-armed rival without going
too far without risking too much
escalation or a miscalculation
it's incumbent upon us to stay number
one to lead the world in future
Industries protect our national security
we are going to build the most advanced
stuff in the world that's where we're at
we're in the middle of another economic
war between big nuclear Powers we don't
know what happens next but one thing
that feels clear to me is that cold war
Vibes are back as these two great Powers
with different ideologies about the
world compete with each other this fight
over chips will continue and this idea
in international relations that I kind
of took for granted which is that like
globalization and interdependence is
good and will lead to less conflict it's
being seriously challenged economic
interdependence is being used as a
weapon that's what we're seeing here and
not just here I made a video a couple
months ago about how Vladimir Putin is
cutting off Natural Gas to Europe
frankly it's not that much different
than Joe Biden cutting off microchips to
China I mean it is different in a lot of
ways blah blah blah we get it but like
the the big mechanics of how this
conflict is playing out peculiar and is
becoming a part of how conflict looks
today so even as this old school style
war continues to rage in Ukraine we're
seeing an evolution of how conflict
Works in our world where once a lot of
conflict revolved around natural
resources like oil most recently the
currency of power we've moved to an Era
where a magical piece of metal-like
substance called silicon whole scene
ones and zeros is kind of the new oil
the new currency of power the new thing
that we should protect to protect our
military Supremacy so in a big shift of
the trend of globalization countries are
now turning inward to protect their
stuff leading to a new era of distrust
severed connection and Rising tensions
okay
okay
semiconductors is over that's it I'm now
going to eat
a Reese's Peanut Butter Cup from Trader
Joe's
um
um that's the end of the video
um thanks to scaler one more time for
sponsoring this video there's a link in
the description that gets you on a free
class if you want to try that out I have
a couple things I want to tell you about
thanks for watching I like to speak into
a microphone at the end because it makes
me feel like I'm a podcaster
should I start a podcast people are
asking me to start a podcast what should
I talk about on my podcast anyway thanks
for watching everyone so um we should
probably talk about The Newsroom so we
make a video an extra video every month
it's a behind the scenes Vlog where we
like capture how all this is made
there's a big team of people lots of
cool fun personalities lots of very
skilled people who touch these videos
I'm just like one Cog in the machine
that video goes live every month and
it's available to people who are members
of The Newsroom uh which is what we call
our patreon I just like to call The
Newsroom because it's like cooler on The
Newsroom you also get access to my
scripts which are like big things that
if maybe if you're like a journalist or
a video Storyteller like could be useful
for you you also get access to Tom fox
tracks Tom Fox is our composer you get
royalty free music that you can use in
your videos if you are a member of The
Newsroom and you get the warm fuzzy
feeling of supporting independent
journalism so um The Newsroom is over on
patreon.com Johnny Harris another thing
that I should mention is that we have
Luts and presets which are like a thing
that you can buy and then you can color
your video or your photos in the way
that we color it we worked with the
professional colors to develop these
things they're basically presets and
they are for photo and video and they
look really nice because I like things
to look nice and welcome to all the new
subscribers here there's been a lot of
new people around the channel lately and
um it's fun to have this community grow
um so I'm gonna keep telling stories and
being curious and learning and looking
for evidence and data and questioning my
assumptions and I appreciate you all
being here so
um I'll see in the next one bye
[Music]